Cancelling birthright citizenship would be
legally difficult. Donald Trump has said he's
interested in it. He's interested in exploring
canceling birthright citizenship. But for
now, if you are born in the physical United
States, you are a citizen unless Donald Trump
gets that changed. It's not happening in the
immediate, but the Trump administration has
maybe found a sort of preemptive proxy to
test eliminating birthright citizenship. And
the Trump administration has changed the policy
for children born to some military service
members and other government employees and
diplomats physically outside of the borders
of the United States. Historically, if you
were born in an overseas military base or
if your parents are diplomats and you're born
in a foreign hospital, I have friends who
are in this situation right now. While your
parents or parent is on diplomatic duty, you
are automatically an American citizen. It's
just, it's an automatic thing that takes place.
The Trump administration is changing this
now. They're not eliminating it. They are
changing the process. Starting October 29th
the process is going to change to one where
the parents must apply for citizenship before
their kid turns 18. Interestingly, I went
through this process to become a citizen.
When my parents became citizens. I then had
the possibility of becoming a citizen up until
age 18 merely by going through a simple administrative
procedure. So for people who don't know, uh,
I and my parents were all born in Argentina
in 1989 my family came to the United States
from Argentina as permanent residents. I was
five years old at the time and then I think
it must have been the mid to late nineties
my parents became citizens of the u s they
had been here, I believe it was seven years
at the time as permanent residents. They went
through the process. They had the entire thing.
It was then up to me whether I wanted to become
a citizen. Now I had two options. If I waited
until age 18 and did not become a citizen,
I would have to go through the entire process.
From the beginning. I would have to apply.
I would have to have the interview and the
entire thing, but until age 18 my parents
could simply go to the post office and request
a passport for me and I would automatically
become a citizen of the United States and
that's what we did. The new Trump policy is
that if your parents are US citizens, but
you happen to be born abroad in a number of
these situations, not all of them. You need
to be naturalized as the phrase is as the
word is. Just like I had to be naturalized
as someone who immigrated to the United States
from another country.
This is ridiculous and it's especially ridiculous
because it serves no real purpose other than
a bureaucratic obstacle. There is no advantage
to this. There was no benefit to this. The
explanation that the u s cis is giving, this
is the u s citizenship and immigration services.
They're saying that this is to align federal
immigration law with State Department procedures.
This is a completely incredible explanation.
By incredible, I mean it is, it is not believable.
It is not credible. This is merely a continuation
of the trends that we've been seeing with
Donald Trump. Trump's not good to the military.
This is a continuation of that. Trump attacks,
gold star gold star families. This is a continuation
of that. Trump attacked prisoner of war, John
McCain for being a prisoner of war, saying
he prefers his war heroes not be captured
or whatever the case may be, and now he wants
to strip military and diplomatic babies of
automatic citizenship.
That's it. That's the storyline. That's the
explanation and if these people, if people
reacted to these things correctly, the military
would turn on Trump and not vote for him in
2020 the farmers would already have turned
on Trump and would not be voting for him in
20 as we've been covering and in the background,
you only need to look at who's running the
u s cis. It's Ken Cuccinelli. Ken Cuccinelli
is an extremist idealog Republican who has
previously said he would like to ban oral
sex. He's a horrible person. He's the acting
director of USC. Of course, there is no permanent
director as is the trend, the status quo under
Donald Trump, but Ken Cuccinelli is the acting
director and the reality of this is that this
is a test to see, can Trump take a baby step
closer to repealing birthright citizenship
altogether? Can he get this through and make
birthright citizenship in total?
The next thing that he wants to repeal, we
should not be confused about the real objectives
here. They are terrible. They are the lowest
of the low. And the question is, will Donald
Trump be given another four years with which
to try to do more of this stuff? Let me know
what you think about this. Let me know what
you think about, uh, the prospects of Trump
re-election. Uh, as of now on Twitter at d
pacman. The show is also on Twitter at David
Pakman show. Follow us both and make sure
that you are watching the live stuff,
dreams that I'm doing on twitch or twitch.tv/gabe
and Pacman, the David Pakman
show@davidpacmandotcomthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpacman.com.